do you think space exploration a
colonizing space is a physics or an
engineering problem what would you say
yeah i think it's fundamentally an
engineering problem if
we're not trying to do
things like
build wormholes the way they did say an
interstellar to get to a different place
or trying to travel near the speed of
light so that we would actually be able
to traverse interstellar distances i
mean without that
our colonization will happen in a very
very slow
rate right um
but one of the beauties of relativity is
if you do travel near the speed of light
you you can actually go arbitrarily far
in a human lifetime people say how's
that possible you can't go billions of
light years well you can actually
because as you can do the split of light
the way in which space and time change
allows you to go in principle
arbitrarily far that's that's very
exciting but if we put that physics side
of the issue
in the manipulation space and time to
the side yeah i think it's a deep
engineering problem you know how
do you terraform other planets i mean
how do you
go beyond our local neighborhood say
without you know using the ideas of
relativity so i think it's all quite
exciting and i think the idea is you
know using solar sails that you know
people have developed and uh you know
trying to take that first step to mars i
think that's a vital and valuable step
to take but yeah i think these are
fundamentally engineering challenges or
extending the human lifespan through
biology research or
maybe reducing what it means to be a
human being into information and
uploading certain parts of it maybe not
all the full resolution of a human life
but maybe the essential things
like the dna and be able to reconstruct
that human being
but
you know i had to ask about mars
you know
do you find
the the dream of humans stepping on mars
stepping foot first but also colonizing
mars
um
one that's worth us fighting for yeah
hugely so i mean i think what we have
long
been not always in the best way
is a species of explorers
in the literal sense of
traveling from one part of the world to
another or in the more metaphorical
sense of trying to travel through our
minds to the quantum realm or back to
the big banger to the center of black
holes so i think that's fundamentally
part of of the human spirit so i do
think that's a vital part of
our heritage brought forward into its
next incarnation that's who we are
do you think there'll be a day
in the future where
a human being is born on mars
and has to
learn about
his or her human origins on earth like
they'll have to read in the book
yeah i don't think it'll be a book at
that stage it'll probably just be
uploaded into the head or something or
you know imprint it into the dna and
then they just sort of sense it but yeah
i think there's there's well look the
the issue you raised before is the vital
one is it the case that any sufficiently
advanced civilization destroys itself
is that sort of a a commonplace quality
i mean that's the other potential answer
to the fermi paradox
why aren't they here because by the time
they got to the technological
development where they could travel here
they blew themselves up they destroyed
themselves and that's a you know you
know an unfortunate but you know
not a hard to imagine
possibility based on things that have
happened here
on planet earth but but putting that to
the side i think it um you know that's
the big obstacle but putting it to the
side we will resolve the engineering
challenges and and you know i should
probably um modify my answer from before
when you said is it engineering or
physics it's really both right so so we
will surmount the engineering challenges
and that will then make the physics
challenges relevant it'll make it
relevant to figure out how to travel
near the speed of light it'll make it
relevant to learn how to manipulate the
shape of space time and so forth so so i
think it's a multi-stage process where
it is engineering and ultimately physics
and if we stick around long enough those
are the kinds of challenges i think that
we're ultimately going to surmount and
on the physics side it's figuring out
how to harness energy enough to travel
outside the solar system which seems
like a heck of a difficult journey but
even mars itself
of um
i don't know maybe because i i was born
in the soviet union and was um
born with the
you know looking up at the stars in that
dream of like the highest of human
achievement his ability to fly out there
to you know to join the stars
i i really like the idea of going to
mars of and not just stepping foot on
mars and it wasn't until
maybe um misinformed but for me
personally
uh it wasn't until elon musk
started talking about the colonization
of mars
did i realize like
we humans can actually do that and the
first of all the importance
of somebody saying that we can do these
seemingly impossible things
is um immeasurable because uh
you know the fact that he he placed that
into my mind
and into the minds of millions of others
maybe hundreds of millions maybe
billions of others
young kids today i mean that that's
going to make it a reality i for some
reason i'm deeply excited
even though my work is an ai
that echoes all of this i'm excited by
the idea that somebody would be born
as we were saying on mars
and sort of look up
and be able to see with the telescope
earth and say that's where i came from
i don't know that
that idea scale to other planets to
other solar systems yeah that's really
exciting and hugely exciting i i think
you're absolutely right i mean the vital
thing
is to dream
right i mean
and it sound hackney but it is so
important
for for young kids for the next
generation
to to think about the things that are
seemingly impossible i mean that's what
makes them possible and this is one
which is concrete enough
i mean this is something that's going to
happen soon in terms of actually going
to mars
and then the next step of establishing
some
presence
some semi-permanent or permanent
presence this is this is not something
that's going to wait to the 25th century
man this is something that's going to
happen relatively soon
so i mean it could well be in your
lifetime unlikely mine but possibly in
your lifetime that that kid will be born
and and have the experience that that
you describe so yeah it's spectacularly
exciting
you